you take the original meaning of the
14th amendment seriously-- is to really
take economic liberties seriously I'm
George Thomas an associate professor of
government at Claremont McKenna College
I specialize in American
constitutionalism american political
thought constitutional law for most of
our history beginning in the late 18th
century and throughout the 19th century
there wasn't this rigid distinction
between personal and civil liberties and
economic liberties of the first in great
Civil Rights Act of 1862 of liberty of
contract the right to own property the
right to convey that property rights
that are now dubbed economic liberties
those those were what they were
describing as civil liberties and those
were sort of first and foremost in their
mind that Liberty included the right to
make choices about your occupation to
make choices about contract the
government could of course regulate
those things in all sorts of ways but it
was limited in how it could regulate
them then and that distinction starts to
get thrown out beginning in the 20th
century as the government begins to
engage in more and more regulation part
of the argument you have in the early
years of the 20th century and you get it
from some quarters but it sort of starts
to disappear is that that you're that
when it comes to economic liberties and
when it comes to say something like
liberty of contract and bar and
bargaining between employers and
employees regarding minimum wages and
maximum hours laws that the state in
some capacity whether it's the state of
the national government needs to
intervene because these are not equal
these are not these are not people in
equal bargaining positions that the
labor is going to be at the mercy of
corporations and therefore they need the
protection of the state but the argument
that really takes shape in the 1930s say
is that these aren't liberties at all
and so you never have a debate about
whether you need adjustment in regard to
civil liberties and instead you end up
with the court urged on by the political
branches simply reading
these liberties out of the Constitution
altogether and so you simply take you
know decades of constitutional history
and logic and say well this was all
wrong this was never part of the
Constitution in any capacity and the
things we're now going to protect these
are civil liberties and economic
liberties don't count most justices
these days tend to view economic Liberty
through what I'd call you deal telling
of history so called lazy fair court is
a invention of progressives and new
dealers and it's in that narrative that
you get economic liberties written out
of the Constitution and in interesting
ways that narrative has more or less
been accepted by liberals and
conservatives and so you don't have
support for economic liberties sort of
across the political spectrum having
digested this new deal telling of
history they tend to think that any
protection of economic liberties was in
fact an instance of justices engaging
their own sort of politics or economics
but both liberals and conservatives and
the terms are sort of difficult to use
on the court but we'll use them for
conventional reasons anyway came to
accept this understanding and so even
original ists like a Justice Scalia for
example view the Constitution through
this lens in part especially the Due
Process Clause and so they've been
reluctant to revisit the early years of
the Fourteenth Amendment and the framing
debates there because they think that
those liberties should not be
legitimately protected I mean what would
be interesting is if they did revisit
the history would they be potentially
persuaded by it
if you took the court's jurisprudence
seriously say from the last twenty years
of the twentieth century and said that
rights named in the Bill of Rights are
subject to what the court calls
heightened scrutiny is there the court
is going to look at them for the laws
that fall upon them far more carefully
and closely and subject them to a much
higher standard than it would other
legislation because they fall within
what it's come to what's come to be
defined as the Liberty protected by the
Fourteenth Amendment Due Process Clause
and yet when the court has actually
turned to one of these clearly Newman
rated rights that is that the Fifth
Amendment guarantees that private
property shall not be taking without
just for public use without just
compensation the court has redefined
that standard in two ways and this this
was sort of most spectacularly done in
the kilo decision kilo V New London a
few years ago the court first of all
applied a lenient standard of review
what it calls the rationality test or a
simple reasonable standard of review to
a textually enumerated right in the
Fifth Amendment the takings Clause so
first of all they water down the
protection available to that right by
plying sort of against its own
presidents a much a much a lower
standard of you than you would normally
get for a right listed in the Bill of
Rights but it also twisted the language
of the Fifth Amendment and turned public
use that's something that the state
could seize for the public to then use
into public purpose and the public
purpose definition is much broader and
it would allow say in the kilo case a
private entity to take public land if it
would use it for potentially more
profitable purposes because there would
be within this private land taken and
given largely to a private corporation
Pfizer corporation who incidentally has
since pulled out of the economic
development dill and so won't be
bringing the jobs and profit that's
supposedly the private homes were seized
for
but because they included within this
space a couple of public parks it looked
like one could say this was for a public
use in some capacity and not simply for
a public purpose but the real logic of
Stephens opinion in kilo seemed to
suggest that any sort of economic
development that might make the state or
the city better off would be an
acceptable standard I mean that so the
the public parks within the broader
economic development scheme sort of
helped fudge public purpose public use I
think the essential logic of Stephens
opinion pointed to economic development
that the state or the city happen to
think would be beneficial and by that
standard it seems that you could seize
blighted property so-called blighted
property from citizen a and hand it over
to private entity be if the state said
well we think B will use it to better
purposes
the privileges and immunities Clause is
potentially going to enjoy your
resurgence and sometimes it seems odd to
say that given that on a nine-member
court you just had eight members say
they didn't want anything to do with the
privileges or immunities clause in the
McDonald uchicago case but in scholarly
circles it's enjoyed a serious
Renaissance and the real question there
then is so what's included in the
privileges or immunities clause you had
for instance a number of academics of a
more liberal persuasion supporting the
petitioner in McDonald v chicago saying
that the privileges or immunities clause
is really where liberties and rights
should be defined in the Fourteenth
Amendment it included Michael ken Curtis
wake forest law school jack balkin of
yale law school as well as prominent
conservatives like Stephen Calabrese of
Northwestern more libertarian scholars
Randy Barnett of Georgetown Law Center
then you have a debate of so how do you
determine what's included in privileges
or immunities and sort of one of the
easy answers is full fundamental rights
but then the question is well what are
fundamental rights and in the 20th
century fundamental rights started out
to include say again middle years of the
20th century with the New Deal Court
they included speech they included
religion they included those things
essentially named within the first eight
amendments of the Constitution the Bill
of Rights those were fundamental rights
but that's broadened over time you now
have a right to privacy which then
included a right to abortion and there's
question is there a fundamental right
say to gay marriage so what what is a
fundamental right is is as part of a
serious debate now what a lot of these
groups don't want is a return to any
form of economic Liberty and anyway they
say somehow those aren't fundamental
rights but that's that's a debate we
ought to have insofar as if you simply
look back to the framing of the
Fourteenth Amendment a number of the
liberties that they were speaking of
fundamental rights is
they might call them on that ought to be
protected by the Fourteenth Amendment
included what we now call economic
liberty so it seems difficult to simply
say well they're not there seems that we
meet we need more of a debate about
wolves they were there why should they
no longer be here